meanwhile tensions are extremely high
tonight between two nuclear powers not
here and the u.s. world leaders are
urging Pakistan and India to take some
deep breaths after two days of the most
intense conflict between the two
countries in 20 years
of course wanna trade yangste has a
roundup tonight from our middle east
newsroom the Pakistani military shot
down two Indian jets today as the
countries clash in the remote Kashmir
region an area the two nuclear powers
have fought over for decades
images show an Indian pilot in Pakistani
custody after reportedly being captured
and beaten by local forces air bases in
Pakistan are reportedly at war alert
levels while Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi gave his military quote a
free hand the incident comes one day
after Indian jets bombed targets in
Pakistan that officials say belonged to
the terrorist group jaish-e-mohammed the
group killed 42 Indian soldiers in a car
bomb attack earlier this month India had
informed about counterterrorism action
it took yesterday a gift a terrorist
training camp objects a moment in
Pakistan based on credible evidence that
that's a moment intended to launch more
attacks India's foreign ministry
spokesman would only confirm that one of
his country's Jets was shot down while
he claimed without evidence of Pakistani
jet was targeted by India in response to
the ongoing territorial conflict
Pakistan briefly closed its airspace as
the two countries tried to avoid a major
conflict I want to ask a question from
the Indian government considering the
nature of the weapons that both of us
have can we afford any miscalculation
should we not think of this moment but
if the situation escalates then where it
will go from the United Kingdom to China
to the European Union leaders are urging
calm and dialogue between India and
Pakistan as both countries possess
nuclear weapons that the international
community fears could be used if a major
war erupts right big story Trey thank
you